[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin guten Abend ihnen allen
alles zum Sport erfahren wir später mit
dir Christin sehr gern guten Abend dann
verschaffen wir uns jetzt einen
Überblick Verzweiflung im Gazastreifen
viele Menschen dort hoffen dass der
Grenzübergang Raffa zu Ägypten
mindestens für Hilfslieferung geöffnet
wird
[Musik]
nach der Parlamentswahl in Polen die
proeuropäische Opposition jubelt jetzt
könnte es einen Machtwechsel
geben kleine Teile große Probleme im
Kampf gegen mikroplastik verbietet die
EU erste Produkte wie Kosmetik oder
Glitter die Situation in narost
verschärft sich zunehmend die
krisendiplomatie läuft auf verschiedenen
Kanälen Kanzler Scholz reist morgen nach
Israel und will danach weiter nach
Ägypten es dürfte um die Befreiung der
inzwischen
199 bestätigten Geiseln und um Schutz
und Versorgung der Zivilisten in Gaza
gehen die stehen zu Tausenden an der
Grenze im Süden des Gazastreifens noch
blockiert Israel in Raffa sowohl
ausreisen nach Ägypten als auch mögliche
Hilfslieferung zur aktuellen Lage Peter
Böhmer Raffa in Ägypten der
Grenzübergang in Gasastreifen gesperrt
dutzende Lastwagen stauen sich warten
dass sie durchfahren dürfen mit ihren
Hilfslieferungen wir haben die
Lieferungen geteilt etwa in Blutspenden
die wir von vielen Menschen bekommen
haben oder auch Medizin und Geräte
zweitens die dringend benötigten
Nahrungsmittel uns helfen hunderte
freiwillige und wir haben Ärzteteams die
parat stehen nach Gaza reinzugehen am
Morgen hieß es in ägyptischen und
israelischen Medien der Grenzübergang
sollte vorübergehend geöffnet werden
unter anderem wegen der Hilfslieferungen
doch dem teilte Israel eine Absage weil
es offenbar befürchtet dass in den LKW
auch Waffen geschmuggelt werden
könnten in den letzten Stunden gab es
Nachrichten als würden wir humanitäre
Hilfe nach Gaza hineinlassen das ist
nicht der Fall die Grenze ist
geschlossen es gibt keine
Feuerpause wir machen weiter mit dem
Krieg und den Attacken auf die
mörderische Terrororganisation
Hamas Israel hat zwar keine territoriale
Gewalt über Rafa aberusges sollten
Ägypter und has ohne Absprache öffnen
würde Israel einschreiten kompliziert
die Lage denn gleichzeitig hieß es
Palästinenser mit doppelter
Staatsangehörigkeit sollen hinausdürfen
das aber binden die Ägypter an die
Einfuhr der Hilfslieferungen an der
Grenze warten auch deutsche aus Duisburg
mit doppelten Pass wohl auf Verwandten
Besuch diese Nacht war sehr sehr
kritisch auch da gab es viele es wurde
viel bombardiert und man konnte nicht
richtig schlafen also wir hatten die
ganze Zeit hat Angst dass
dass unser Haus sozusagen bombardiert
wird nun hängen sie fest und es ist
völlig unklar wie das Problem an der
Grenze gelöst werden
kann in Israel ist Michael berung in der
Nähe des Gazastreifens Michael in Gaza
staut es sich an der Grenze zu Ägypten
Israel blockiert wohl die Öffnung und
soll auch den Grenzübergang beschossen
haben kannst du das
bestätigen ja in der Tat kann ich
bestätigen dass es einen Bombenangriff
gab ich habe mit einem Mitarbeiter von
uns im Süden von Gaza gesprochen das
Interessante an diesem Luftangriff ist
dass es keine Verletzten oder gar Toten
gab ich interpretiere das als klare
Warnung Israels dass niemand es wagen
soll einfach so versuchen
humanitäre Lieferungen in in den
gaserastreifen zu bringen unser
Mitarbeiter berichtet auch dass hunderte
ausländische Staatsbürger an der Grenze
am Grenzübergang ausharen und zugleich
von dramatischen Zuständen auf den
Straßen von Junis das ist eine Stadt
direkt in Nähe im Süden von Raffa die
Menschen schlafen auf der nackten Straße
weil sie keine Unterkunft haben es gibt
so gut wie keine Lebensmittel mehr und
kaum Wasser trotzdem ist Israel nicht
bereit einen humanitären Korridor zu
öffnen es gab heute die Meldung dass das
un flüchtlingswerk von der Hamas mit
bestohlen worden sei dass Medikamente
und Benzin entwendet worden war das
trägt nicht dazu bei einen solchen
Korridor zu öffnen mit der Argumentation
das würde ja nur der Herm nützen und es
gibt viele Mitglieder in der Regierung
die sagen wenn es einen humanitären
Korridor gibt dann nur im Austausch mit
Geiseln danke für die Information live
aus Israel Michael
bewerunge im Nahostkonflikt hat
Jordanien seit vielen Jahren eine
bedeutende Vermittlerrolle helfen
könnten deshalb auch zwei
Gesprächstermine in Berlin
Bundespräsident Steinmeier hat dort
Jordaniens König abdollah den i
empfangen mit ihm wird sich morgen früh
auch Kanzler Scholz treffen Abdullah der
Z genießt Respekt in der westlichen und
in der arabischen Welt und zur Lage in
nost senden wir auch ein ZDF Spezial
direkt im Anschluss hier an unsere
Sendung nach dem hamasterror wird bei
uns darüber diskutiert wie man Hass und
Hetze auf deutschen Straßen unterbinden
kann einige Städte wie Hamburg Schränken
aktuell proalästinensische Kundgebungen
aus Sorge vor Straftaten und
Ausschreitungen ein daran gibt es
allerdings auch Kritik Christiane
hübscher berichtet verlassen sie den
Platz angemeldet war eine mannwache mit
50 Personen doch innerhalb kürzester
Zeit wird daraus eine proalästinensische
Demonstration mit mehr als 1000 Menschen
gestern in Berlin Mitte die Polizei
erklärt die Versammlung für verboten und
löst sie auch mit körperlicher Gewalt
auf 127 Demonstranten werden kurzzeitig
festgenommen das Versammlungsrecht sei
ein hohes Gut so die
bundesinnenministerin hier beim Besuch
der Frankfurter jüdischen Gemeinde eine
einheitliche Linie für
Demonstrationsverbot ist schwierig die
Behörden müssten im Einzelfall abwägen
ob z.B Terror verherrlicht werde ich bin
sehr froh dass die meisten
Verwaltungsgerichte auch
Oberverwaltungsgerichte am Wochenende
entschieden haben dass solche ähm
Versammlung auch verboten wurden und
dass das Verbot gehalten hat dennoch kam
es dann zu spontanen Zusammenkünften die
müssen dann aber auch konsequent wieder
aufgelöst werden der Vertreter der
palästinensischen Autonomiebehörde in
Deutschland kritisiert die
Einschränkungen ich bin zutiefst besorgt
über die übertriebene Reaktion auf eine
friedliche antikriegsdemonstration
gestern in Berlin der Verfassungsschutz
sieht sich derweil gefordert wie lange
nicht eine Krise die sich direkt auf
deutsche Sicherheitsinteressen auswirke
deshalb ist es wichtig dass sich jetzt
an die dieser Stelle der Staat wehrhaft
zeigt ich halte die von Kanzler Scholz
angekündigten Betätigung und
vereinsverbote für erforderlich wir
werden alle Anstrengungen unternehmen um
das so schnell wie möglich auch
umzusetzen dabei ginge es um mehr als
die zwei bereits geplanten
vereinsverbote es sei eine ganze Palette
von Organisationen die man genauer
betrachten müsse so
haltenwang Deutschland verschärft die
Kontrollen an den Grenzen zur Schweiz
Polen und Tschechien so soll
schleuserkriminalität bekämpft und
irreguläre Migration begrenzt werden
hieß es aus dem
Innenministerium die Kontrollen sind
zunächst für 10 Tage vorgesehen und
sollen sich so wenig wie möglich auf
Pendler Handel und Reiseverkehr
auswirken in Polen könnte sich nach der
gestrigen Parlamentswahl ein
Machtwechsel anbahnen die seit 8 Jahren
regierende erzkonservative peace ist
zwar stärkste Partei geworden bräuchte
aber zum Regieren Partner die bislang
nicht in Sicht sind es wäre die Chance
für das proeuropäische Lager um
Oppositionsführer Donald Tusk über die
Ausgangslage nach der Wahl die ein neues
Verhältnis zu Polen einleuten könnte
Andreas
küer als der bisher mächtigste Mann
Polens als jaroswav katinski am
Nachmittag hinter verdunkelten Scheiben
in die PiS Parteizentrale fährt muss er
etwas tun das er bis gestern nicht getan
hat er muss nett sein zur Opposition
dass die P um an der Macht zu bleiben
einen Partner bräuchte ist der
Paukenschlag der letzten
Nacht Frage ist ob es möglich sein wird
unseren Erfolg in eine weitere Amtszeit
unserer Regierung zu
verwandeln als ungünstig erweist sich
nach der Wahl dass katinski vor der Wahl
denkbare Partner wie die Bauernpartei
als bnausen und Faulpelze bezeichnet hat
sie wird Kinskis Angebot he
ahnenamit kön linke das konservative
Parteienbündnis dritter Weg und die
bürgerkoalition von Donald Tusk eine
Koalition bilden die rechtsextreme
konfederatia und die peace kommen auch
zusammen nicht auf eine
Mehrheit wir haben es geschafft wirklich
so lange und so leidenschaftlich hat die
Bürgerplattform noch nie einen zweiten
Platz gefeiert nach 8 Jahren
rechtsnationaler eu-skeptischer Politik
tanzt die Opposition einer neuen
Regierung entgegen Polen hat gewonnen
die Demokratie hat gewonnen wir haben
die peace von der Macht
entfernt ich hoffe dass es jetzt mehr
Demokratie geben
wird die Regierungspartei hätte mehr
Stimmen bekommen sollen vielleicht
zählen sie die auslandsstimmen noch
irgendwie rein es hat im In und im
Ausland lange gedauert bis die letzte
Stimme abgegeben war in Breslau etwa bis
3 Uhr morgens es hat Polen vielleicht
für lange Zeit
verändert da lohnt sich die Nachfrage
bei Natalie Steger vor dem same dem
Parlament in Warschau Natalie wir haben
gerade das tanzende proeuropäische Lager
um Tusk gesehen wie sicher können sie
sich sein an die Regierung zu
kommen also von den Zahlen her könnten
sie sich eigentlich mittlerweile sicher
sein 85% der Stimmen sind ausgezählt und
dieses Dreierbündnis das hat die klare
Mehrheit stand jetzt und das wird wohl
auch von den Zahlen her so bleiben aber
es besteht die Möglichkeit dass die
peace auf Zeit spielt der
Staatspräsident duda der heute im
Vatikan weilt und nicht in Polen an dem
wichtigen Tag der Staatspräsident duda
hat nun se Wochen lang Zeit und er ist
ein peacemann jemanden mit der
Regierungsbildung zu beauftragen in
dieser Zeit hat katinski moravieet und
ihre peace haben Zeit und können
versuchen jemanden aus dem
Oppositionslager rüber zuziehen aber
Andy küers hat gerade in seinem Beitrag
gesagt es sieht nicht gut aus für K es
sieht aus dass die Opposition
tatsächlich geschlossen wie selten
bleibt in Polen dann würde katinski dann
würde die peace scheitern und dann würde
tatsächlich Donald Tusk wohl
Ministerpräsident von Polen AR in ein
aber gibt es
noch man könnte versuchen katinski
könnte versuchen gegen die Gültigkeit
der Wahlen zu klagen und noch mal Zeit
zu gewinnen also mit katinski mit der
Pace ist alle mit allem zu rechnen wenn
er an der Macht kleben will auch wenn es
für mich tatsächlich nach einem
Machtwechsel auf lange Sicht aus
aussieht danke schön nach Warschau
Natalie
Steger die mögliche EU-Erweiterung in
Richtung Westbalkan darum ging es heute
bei einem Treffen in der albanischen
Hauptstadt Tiran an dem auch Kanzler
Scholz teilnahm zu den sechs Ländern die
beitreten wollen gehören Serbien und
Kosovo deren aktueller Grenzkonflikt das
Treffen überschattete Scholz und
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Lin
forderten beide Seiten auf ihre
Spannungen beizulegen
nach Afghanistan das Land wird gerade
besonders hart getroffen mehrfach in gut
einer Woche ist der Nordwesten von
schweren Beben erschüttert worden
zuletzt wieder in der Region um die
Stadt her diesmal mit der Stärke
6,3 normalerweise sind Erdbeben in der
Gegend eine Seltenheit insgesamt kamen
mehr als 1000 Menschen ums Leben und nur
sehr langsam dringt Hilfe bis zu der
meistarmen Bevölkerung durch Kamran
an sie graben dort wo früher ihr Haus
stand gulahmad und sein Bruder Ahmad sie
wohnten Haus an Haus mit ihren Frauen
und Kindern von ihrem Dorf najibrafi
50 km von Herod entfernt ist wenig übrig
über 300 Tote vor allem wer im Freien
war hat überlebt die Brüder haben
Angehörige
verloren wir waren zu Hause als die Erde
bebte ich schaffte es verletzt raus dann
stürzten alle Häuser um mich herum ein
Sohn und meine Frau sind jetzt tot mein
Sohn war
sieben zuletzt erschütterten gleich drei
schwere Erdbeben die Gegend um die
Provinzhauptstadt heraut die aus Lehen
gebauten Häuser stürzten einfach
ein die meisten Opfer Frauen und Kinder
über 2000 verletzte bisher viele werden
im Krankenhaus in herut behandelt was
ganz wichtig für uns immer ist dass wir
Sie schnell mit sauberem Trinkwasser
versorgen damit keine Krankheiten
ausbrechen gerade
für kleine Kinder ist es besonders
wichtig dass sie keinen Durchfall jetzt
bekommen weil das kann sehr schnell
tödlich werden und das in einem Land in
dem bereits die Hälfte der Kinder unter
5 Jahren unterährt ist
Hilfsorganisationen liefern das Nötigste
bauen Zelte doch Nachbeben Stürme und
Kälte erschweren die Lage auch für die
Brüder gulahmad und
Ahmad wir haben hier alles verloren
letzte Nacht wären wir fast vor Kälte
gestorben nicht mit einer Decke
Überleben der Sturm hat alle Zelte
zerstört wir brauchen dringend eine
Unterkunft die Familie traumatisiert ihr
droht eine weitere unruhige und kalte
Nacht jetzt zu einem ganz anderen Thema
mikroplastik jährlich gelangen Tonnen
davon in die Umwelt ein Teil davon
nehmen auch wir Menschen auf und merken
es gar nicht dagegen will die EU jetzt
vorgehen zumindest schrittweise
langfristig sollen die diverse Produkte
verboten werden die zugesetztes
mikroplastik enthalten etwa
Kinderspielzeug oder Granulat wie es auf
Kunstrasenplätzen verwendet wird jetzt
geht's aber erst einmal um Kosmetik und
beautypukte Sven rieen mit
mehr einfacher loser Glitter mit
mikroplastik ist nach der neuen
eureelung verboten die gleichen Partikel
in Gel gebunden sind allerdings
weiterhin erlaubt auch in anderen
Kosmetikprodukten darf mikroplastik
weiterhin eingesetzt werden von dem
Verkaufsverbot ist hier nur ein
Produktbereich betroffen das was sie
definitiv als Peeling einsetzen sie
wollen sich da was runterrippeln von der
Haut irgendwelche alten Hautzellen was
auch immer sie da Abschuppen wollen die
sind jetzt sozusagen nicht mehr mit
mikroplastik zulässig waren allerdings
kaum mehr mit mikroplastik auf dem Markt
das Verbot von mikroplastik in Shampoo
und Duschgel greift 2027 in Pflege und
Reinigungsmitteln 28 Cremes und Haargels
sind ein Jahr später dran das Granulat
auf Sportplätzen 2031 und 35 gilt das
Verbot beim Make-up freiwillig
verzichten geht schon jetzt auf die
Inhaltsstoffe schaue ich schon ja wegen
dem Plastik ja ich habe nichts dagegen
wenn es nicht drin ist ja ich habe auch
nichts dagegen wenn es kein Glitzer mehr
gibt das alles vollkommen in Ordnung und
die Inhaltsstoffe kenne ich mich nicht
so ganz aus aber ich achte dann drauf
dass es allgemein bekannt ist dass es
naturkosmetigk ist ja die Übergangszeit
für das plastikverbot im Bereich
Kosmetik beträgt also 12 Jahre viel zu
lang für Umweltschützer die
Langzeitfolgen sind einfach überhaupt
nicht klar was wir aber wissen ist dass
wenn wir mikroplastik in der Umwelt
ausbringen wir so gut wie keine Chance
haben es da wieder zurückzuholen das
heißt wir machen etwas wovon wir nicht
wissen was die Konsequenzen sein werden
in der Kosmetikbranche gibt es längst
unbedenkliche Alternativen das jetzt
greifende mikroplastikverbot gilt
übrigens nur für den Verkauf die Nutzung
von Beständen ist weiterhin
erlaubt so jetzt zu was anderes zu
anderem was glitzert diese sechs Romane
die Waren zum Schluss noch im Rennen und
einer hat vor wenigen Minuten den
Deutschen Buchpreis gewonnen und wird
damit als bester deutschsprachiger Roman
ausgezeichnet die Preisverleihung findet
traditionell am Tag vor dem Start der
Frankfurter Buchmesse statt Inken Klinge
stellt uns jetzt Buch und Autor
vor Tonio Schachinger für
echtzeitalter
der Deutsche Buchpreis geht in diesem
Jahr an den 31-Jährigen Österreicher
Tonio Schachinger der in seinem Roman
echtzeitalter über die Schulzeit
schreibt er arbeitet mit einer gewissen
ironischen Distanz die aber niemals
überheblich wird und ist wirklich ein
großer Erzähler und man folgt ihm gerne
in die Katakomben dieser dieser Schule
dieses schulkosmos der ja völlig aus der
Zeit gefallen ist echtzeitalter spielt
in einem traditionsreichen Internat in
die meisten Kinder hier am Marianum
stammen aus wohlhabenden Familien mit
Einfluss der ruhige till ist anders will
nicht so richtig in die elitäre Umgebung
hineinpassen ist nach der Scheidung
seiner Eltern hier gelandet dann stirbt
auch noch sein Vater til flüchtet in die
Welt der Computerspiele dort ist er
richtig gut doch das interessiert am
alteehrwürdigen Gymnasium mit Teil
strengen Lehrern nicht es ist so diese
Welt wo man sich darstellen möchte als
eben nicht nur reich sondern auch
gebildet und dafür braucht man so ein
bisschen Bildung zum Drüberstreuen aber
eigentlich geht's nicht um Bildung
sondern eigentlich geht's nur darum
seinen seinen sozialen Status zu
verfestigen ein Buch über das
Erwachsenwerden mühelos erzählt aber
nicht nur mit viel Humor stellt Tonio
Schachinger Autoritäten und Traditionen
in der österreichischen Gesellschaft in
Frage und konnte sich damit in der
Endrunde
durchsetzen für die olympischen
winterspiele6 in Mailand und Cortina
dampzo da wird aus finanziellen Gründen
kein neuer Eiskanal gebaut und jetzt
brauchen die Italiener ein Ausweichort
Christin und das im Ausland das gab's
tatsächlich noch nie Deutschland hat
bereits abgewunken und steht als
ersatzgastgeber nicht zur Verfügung aber
Österreich bietet sich mit der
Olympiabahn von 76 an innsbrur wäre
bereit die olympischen Wettbewerbe 26 im
Skeleton Bob und Rodeln auszutragen
Markus h in Mumbai ein anderes Thema
beim IOC Kongress bezieht sich auf die
Fortsetzung der Amtszeit von Präsident
thomas Bach wofür aber sogar die
olympische Karter geändert werden
müsste so eine Art Gesetzesänderung wäre
notwendig damit der deutsche über 2025
hinaus im Amt bleiben könnte mehrere IOC
Mitglieder haben sich dafür
ausgesprochen es wirkte wohl organisiert
und orchestriert sie alle hatten ihre
Skripte vorbereitet damit sie ihre Liebe
ihrem Präsidenten gegenüber ausschütten
können es hatte etwas von Bollywood in
Mumbai Thomas bachel wollte sich nicht
dazu äußern ob er weitermachen will oder
wird aber so wie man ihn und das IOC
kennt ist das höchstwahrscheinlich nur
eine Taktik und eine Frage der Zeit und
mit Good Governance und einer
Amtszeitbeschränkung hätte das rein gar
nicht zu tun Markus vielen Dank für
diese Einschätzung zum Tennis Rückschlag
für Alexander SEV durch sein erstrunden
aus in Tokyo in zwei Sätzen gegen den
Australier Thomson verpasst er weitere
wichtige Punkte zu sammeln für das ATP
Saisonfinale der acht besten pro in
Turin ist derzeit s bei der Rugby WM in
Frankreich stehen die Halbfinalisten
fest vier Teams von vier Kontinenten
Argentinien Neuseeland England und als
letzte qualifizierten sich die
Südafrikaner ganz knapp mit 29 Z8 gegen
die französischen
Gastgeber alles drin alles dran an
diesem vorweggenommenen Finale die
blauen aus Frankreich liegen vor über
weite Strecken doch die 19 z12 Führung
ist mit einem Schlag dahin als die
Südafrika ihre gelle ins Rennen
schicken unaufhaltsam der
Titelverteidiger punktet wenn er muss
wer kann schon so einen Schrank von Mann
aufhalten 23 groß 117 kg schwer legt den
Franzosen ein Ei ins Nest Südafrika im
Halbfinale Frankreich raus so etwas haut
den stärksten Mann
umetter jeder merk das dermer plus
gerade noch T-Shirt Temperaturen jetzt
Gänsehaut Feeling im Erzgebirge scheint
der Herbst sogar ganz übersprungen
worden zu sein winteridülle weiß in weiß
zwar bildeten die Flocken nur eine dünne
Decke aber es reichte für die vermutlich
ersten Schneemänner der Saison und auch
tatsächlich für die erste
Schneeballschlacht also wir müssen uns
da ein bisschen umstellen jetzt langsam
ob wir auch noch mit normalem
Herbstwetter rechnen dürfen dazu gleich
mehr von Katja horneffer um 21:45 Uhr
Marietta slomker mit dem heute journal
hier begrüßt sie morgen dann Jana
pareiges nach dem wettergleich unser ZDF
Spezial zur Lage in nost schönen Dank
und auf
[Musik]
bald guten Abend jetzt hat die kalte
Luft Mitteleuropa geflutet das hängt
zusammen mit diesem hoch das jetzt
langsam weiter ostwärts zieht wir
brauchen den Blick aber nicht weit
schweifen zu lassen nämlich nur auf den
Atlantik da kringelt sich bereits ein
neues tief ein und das könnte zum
Donnerstag von Südwesteuropa noch mal
für deutlich höhere Temperaturen bei uns
Sorgen zumindest mal im Südwesten
Deutschlands heute Nacht aber wird's
erstmal kalt da sinken die Temperaturen
auf +3 bis -3° es droht also verbreitet
Bodenfrost da sollten Sie Ihre
empfindlichen Pflanzen schützen milder
bleibt Nacht an den Küsten von Ost und
nordse auch am niederrein bei 10 bis 4°
heute Nacht ist es mal mehr mal weniger
stark bewölkt es bildet sich auch Nebel
wenn der sich morgen auflöst scheint
häufiger mal die Sonne zum Teil ist es
aber auch stärker bewölkt wie im Süden
oder auch im Osten Deutschlands in
schlißlich holzstein reicht auch für
einige Regenschauer die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 10 und 16° dabei ist es im
Osten insgesamt etwas kühler als im
Westen und dann ändert sich das Wetter
noch nicht sofort aber zum Freitag da
Sturm und am Samstag könnte es dann für
Schneefälle selbst im Flachland reichen
guten Abend